almost 6 000 miles away from tokyo
this is home for lauren price hernan and
auntie are still in
awe of their boxing champ even her dog
buster
is decked out in olympic glory i was
crying i was in tears
tears of joy obviously but um
elated for her because she's been so
blooming hard for this
you know since she's eight years of age
she's
she has three dreams to follow and she's
achieved them all
what else is left you know and you must
be so proud as well
just ecstatic absolutely over the moon
for her
lauren price is an exceptional athlete
she's mastered kickboxing
and has 52 caps playing football for
wales but she wanted to go to the
olympic games and made the move to
boxing becoming commonwealth world
and european champion and now olympic
gold
this is where her boxing career began
at a local community club her first
coach was delighted to see her win in
tokyo
we're really proud really when she
looked 15 16
she had a brother here as well and they
but she was not very fast and
on fast feet but she was very calm and
collective
others at the gym also remember training
with lauren
for a 15 year old she could she was
strong and i i knew
straight away you know how special she
was and she's easy going she's bubbly
she's fun
yeah she's a good laugh she's very laid
back as well
the boxing club sits in an area that's
seen its fair share of hardship right in
the heart of the welsh valleys
olympic gold now putting it firmly on
the international map
during the games lauren has spoken of
how text messages from nan at home have
kept her focused
i still only text with one finger i
usually say
dream dream big follow your dream
don't forget now you're on the moon it's
time to land
and all this is up to you we just make
sure it's a soft landing
and we'll always be there we within our
hearts
her family hope the post box right
outside lauren's window will soon be
painted
olympic gold and they say she'll stay in
the amateur sport
and go for double glory in paris in
three years time
harriet hadfield sky news south wales